les formes modernes de distribution nous
pousse insidieusement à la
surconsommation et au gaspi nous sommes
dans les années 70 la société de
consommation qui a émergé à la moitié du
20e siècle est à son apogée
certains chercheurs et politiques
commencent alors à s'inquiéter des
conséquences de ce nouveau mode de vie
au gaspillage industrielle était en
première ligne dans le temps il est
absolument impensable de chuter quelque
chose d'un petit peu important on avait
déjà du mal à jeter des aliments achetés
un morceau de pain c'est vrai ben non on
se contente pas acheter du pain ou juge
t'elle rochette des vêtements et même
des montres
c'est très bien on change de monde tous
les jours autre point noir évoqué par ce
chercheur la surproduction de déchets
mais de 30 à 40 % des emballages ne sert
strictement à rien on doit parfaitement
s'en passer donc c était des matières
premières qui sont qui sont gras chez
pour rien en 1977 sur le plateau de
l'émission aujourd'hui madame
l'écologiste rené dumont alerte et lui
sur le gaspillage énergétique en du
genre au double quand je rejoins
d'énergie électoraux locaux disent qu'au
bout de 10 ans ne deux fois plus heureux
parce qu'on ne continue nos populations
face à cette réalité mais aussi face à
la crise pétrolière qui fragilise
l'économie
le gouvernement de l'époque décide de
réagir politique anti gaspillage est
lancé dès 1974 par le premier ministre
jacques chirac
je me propose d'engager tous les
français tous les français à faire un
effort pour sortir de ce qui est
incontestablement une économie de
gaspillage
pour le gouvernement le recyclage des
déchets apparaît alors comme l'une des
solutions
savez vous que pratiquement on pourrait
diminuer de moitié la consommation de
papier
si l'on mettait en oeuvre les procédures
les procédés techniquement existants ou
au point où à développer de récupération
du papier et des cartons mais
naturellement on ne s'en était pas
jusqu'ici inquiété il faudra s'en
inquiéter certaines initiatives locales
rejoignait déjà la volonté du premier
ministre en normandie par exemple un
groupe de jeunes récupérerai papiers et
cartons pour les réutiliser pour ces
jeunes gens il s'agissait de convaincre
les consommateurs que nous sommes
maintenant on dira les gaspilleurs de
mes plus belles les journaux revues ou
cartons et on ramasse beaucoup plus
facilement beaucoup mieux chez les vieux
les jeunes les jeunes les jeunes fans le
problème très légèrement triste que les
vieux ont beaucoup plus conscience de la
notion de l'argent de sa représenté 8 h
surtout aujourd'hui le recyclage fait
partie du quotidien des français mais
n'est pas un réflexe pour tous selon
l'observatoire du geste de tri seuls 48%
triste systématiquement leurs emballages
moins d'un français sur deux
[Musique]